à
ce pourrait être un ciel étoilé
vu depuis n'importe où sur terre
mais il n'en est rien
[Musique]
il y a quelques semaines deux hommes ont
débarqué dans ce lieu unique
ils en ont foulé le sol sablonneux et se
sont pris pour des pionniers de la
conquête spatiale
alors là on est sur mars donc on peut
quand même apercevoir de mars la voie
lactée au niveau des étoiles on a le
sable martien juste à nos pieds avec les
roches martiennes que l'on peut
découvrir ici et on marche sur la
planète rouge à plusieurs millions de km
de la terre
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
croire ces deux hommes ne plaisante pas
totalement romain charles 30 ans ici à
droite et jérôme clevers 28 ans sont
membres de l' agence spatiale européenne
il prépare un futur voyage vers mars
alors c'est une option très sérieuse on
n'est pas dans un reality show ou
quelque chose comme ça non on est ici
pour pour essayer de faire avancer la
science et pour faire avancer la
conquête spatiale donc vers mars et le
principal le sujet de cette mission
c'est l'homme est il capable de faire le
chemin aller et retour sur la surface
martienne
évidemment la planète mars où ils
viennent de poser le pied n'est qu'une
reproduction et ses hangars n'est qu'une
petite partie de l'incroyable expérience
qu'ils vont bientôt vivre ici
l'opération s'appelle marc 500 comme le
nombre de jours que vont passer six
cobayes enfermés dans ces conteneurs en
métal
plus exactement 5 120 jours le temps
nécessaire pour un aller retour sur la
planète rouge soit 50 fois plus que pour
la lune
l'objectif de cette mission est
d'étudier les effets d'un long
confinement sur l'homme pour préparer un
futur voyage vers mars
romain est le seul français à participer
à cette expérience unique au monde et
rien ne le prédestinait à une telle
aventure
[Musique]
une aventure qui se déroule à moscou en
russie
le pays qui a envoyé le premier homme
dans l'espace romain va vivre cette
longue expérience avec cinq autres
personnes
il n'a rien d'un astronaute
professionnels
en france il n'était qu'un simple
ingénieur qualité dans une ligne de
pièces détachées pour automobiles cette
mission totalement folle c'est un peu
l'expérience de sa vie je suis tout
petit comme tous les garçons je rêvais
d'être astronaute et en fait ce rêve
j'ai voulu me garder voire plus du temps
et dans ma carrière toujours gardé cette
petite idée si une opportunitée se
présente il faut que je sois capable de
sauter dessus
j'ai sauté sur l'occasion mais avant
d'en arriver là
romain dû subir toute une batterie de
tests contrôle médical questionnaire
psychologique entretien de motivation
etc
il a finalement été retenu parmi 250
candidats européens avec notamment diego
un italien et jérôme un belge qui lui
n'est que remplaçant en cas de problème
avant l'embarquement
comme tous les matins ils arrivent sur
les lieux de leurs futures missions
au milieu des tours de banlieue voici le
centre de sélection des cosmonautes
russes
c'est dans cet immense bâtiment qui a
été installé le vaisseau spatial ou vont
séjourner les candidats à l'isolément là
en fait on est on est donc à l'intérieur
du bâtiment qui va contenir l'ensemble
de l'expérience et du module et on voit
en partie le module donc on marre on
sait la surface martienne et derrière on
a le module de vie où il ya les chambres
cuisine salon salle à manger un
appartement composé de cinq questions de
métal connectés entre eux par des sas et
bardée de capteurs
surface habitable 180 m² pour six
occupants a priori confortable mais
jérôme et romain s'attendent à des
moments difficiles car même si le
vaisseau de décollera jamais les
conditions d'un long voyage spatial
ils seront reproduits au détail près la
pesanteur en moins et ça ne s'annonce
pas comme une partie de plaisir
à commencer par la nourriture
tout ce qui est frigon pour la
nourriture congelée
finis les petits plats maison pendant
520 jours ils ne mangeront que des repas
lyophilisés ou surgelés côté déco c'est
un environnement métallique sans
fenêtres ni lumière naturelle
l'équipage sera livré à lui-même y
compris en matière de santé leur ange
gardien un système de vidéo surveillance
24 heures sur 24
donc on a des caméras de surveillance
c'est parfait pour du big brother c'est
vraiment fait pour quelqu'un venait à
tomber malade ou tomber je suis pas
unanimes et pour dieu sait quelle raison
par dans le module il faut pouvoir
avertir les secours extérieurs et au
sein de ce loft version spatiale un seul
endroit pour se défouler voilà dans la
salle de sport une salle de gym
rudimentaire ont chaque membre
d'équipage devra s'entraîner deux heures
par jour pour récolter des données sur
l'évolution de son état physique
seul souci il y à bien une douche au
fond du module mello il sera très
rationnés là c'est ce qui va nous servir
de douche
bon je trouve qu'elle est plutôt grande
et confortable ce qui est pas souvent
dans le module ont par contre les
douches seront très limités puisque la
consommation d'eau est très limité dans
l'espace
on n'a pas le droit à prendre plus d'une
douche par dix jours et par nombre
d'équipages des douches très rare est
impossible de laver le moindre vêtement
il faudra tenir trois jours avec le même
caleçon et six jours avec le même
t-shirt
en tout chaque participant devra
embarquer 500 kg de vêtements qui une
fois portée seront évacués dans le
cosmos du moins virtuellement
ok donc ça c'est la poubelle de l'espace
donc c'est un tout petit sas donc l on y
mêle et les vêtements par exemple
inutile ou qui ne servent plus on les
dépose à on referme et on appuie sur le
bouton qui permet donc de faire le vide
et d'aspirer les vêtements vers
l'extérieur hormis les conditions
d'hygiène c'est la routine de cette vie
très carcérale qui risque de poser
problème
le module musicale j'ai un petit peu
plus difficile d'accès au bout du tunnel
voici leur lieu de travail
huit heures par jour l'équipage
réalisera ici une centaine d'expériences
scientifiques lient aux conséquences du
confinement sur l'homme
et pour dormir on est bien loin du 4
étoiles
trois quarts et un tout petit peu moins
de 30 mètres carrés donc avec un lit qui
n'est pas conventionnel petit mais très
étroits comme on peut le voir ce qu'il
fait il est très petit pour choisir 65
60 centimes de l'heure le reste du temps
soit huit heures au quotidien ils se
passeront dans une salle de repos plutôt
monacale donc voilà la zone de vie c'est
là où on se regroupera pour l'étendre de
pose de loisirs avec la petite
bibliothèque pour l'instant mais l'un
des plus grands défis pour cet équipage
entièrement masculin ce sera d'apprendre
à mettre en veilleuse sa libido
je pense qu'il faudra que la motivation
prennent le pas sur ce genre de de désir
de volonté le dessus il faut qu'on se
prépare pour ça et ça sera une part
d'habitude c'est comprendre l'impact de
tout ça manque 520 jours coupés du monde
sans relation amoureuse et dans un
confort spartiate
ça s'annonce difficile pour romain et
ses collègues mais qu'en est il pour
leurs proches
à saint malo en bretagne quelques jours
avant le début de la mission saint malo
quand même on a mis quelques pages
dessus un séance photos souvenirs chez
romain en compagnie d'hélène sa petite
amie vous fameux voyage à new york en
mai il donc là ça va bien non et ouais
c'était ctg ans à quinze jours intenses
on avait peu dormi hélène a préparé tout
un album de photos que romain doit
emmener avec lui en mission ça fait un
an et demi qu'ils sont ensemble coucher
de soleil vacances des fois ici la jeune
femme infirmière accepté de quitter sa
région natale pour venir habiter ici
avec son nouvel ami mais hélène 24 ans
ne vit pas très bien le départ de son
compagnon car elle ne s'attendait pas
vraiment à ce qu'il soit recruté soit il
a commencé à me parler de ce projet
l'âge je croyais pas du tout enfin je la
limite je pousse à le faire parce que
bon on revient de façon il va jamais et
finalement j'ai vu évoluer petit à petit
dans le recrutement réussir petit à
petit les étapes
c'est vrai que je voyais que pour moi
c'était pas forcément quelque chose de
positif quand même si je le voyais
réalisé son rêve un rêve qui pourrait
coûter bien cher à romain car loin des
yeux loin du coeur et cela pendant un an
et demi hélène a déjà pris de grandes
décisions
[Musique]
je vais retourner chez moi en normandie
et je vais refaire une vie là bas je
vais trouver un nouveau boulot et et
revoir mes amis
voilà je vais vivre de mon côté ça va
pas m'empêcher c'est dangereux pour vos
mains je préfère la voir vivre de son
côté et vivre que s'enfermer ici où elle
connaît très peu de gens et où elles
seraient de plus en plus mal aux
forcément pendant tout ce temps romain
et hélène pourront tout de même
s'échanger des petits mots par courrier
électronique
mais le plus étonnant c'est que le jeune
ingénieur est parfois confronté à
l'incompréhension de son entourage
démonstration au sein de son entreprise
dont il vient de démissionner pour cause
d'expériences martienne certains
collègues de bureau ont un peu de mal à
saisir l'intérêt de sa démarche
j'ai dit au revoir à vous embêter un
petit peu bonjour d'abord une il
pas d'aller vivre la boxe je pose c'est
quoi l'objectif de ce sommet soit c'est
de répondre à une question est ce que
fit psychologiquement et
physiologiquement l'homme est capable
d'aller sur mars
déjà je vois pas l'intérêt jade une
femme et c'est pas méchant mais je
l'accepté ton trip c'est cool mais moi
je vois pas du tout l'intérêt d'aller
sur mars
en plus c'est dans 30 ans de ce premier
voyage sur mars est prévue dans 20 ou 30
ans si l'argent est la prière il a toute
chose à voir sur terre trop de choses
qu'on connaît pas sur terre et enfin les
fonds marins des gestes comme ça
pourquoi ils sont béthéry à chercher des
trucs là où je peux vous avez été trop
longtemps
je passe la tête à l'heure mais il en
faudrait davantage pour ébranler romain
de le côté attiré cas d'autant plus
qu'il va bientôt toucher du doigt son
rêve d'enfant retour à moscou
derrière les murs du centre de formation
des cosmonautes
se déroule un test un peu spécial
sous le regard très concentré d'un
savant russe
jérôme le torse bardet d'électrodes et
diego tuyaux dans la bouche ne semble
pas très à la fête
savatier go sans nom comment ça va
choquer choqué c'est une particule
jérôme et diego sont en pleine exercices
respiratoires
les scientifiques veulent mesurer
l'influencé du confinement sur leur état
de santé
super les membres d'équipage devront
répéter cette expérience
tout au long de leur mission pour romain
pas de test d'effort aujourd'hui mais un
exercice beaucoup plus sympathique que
cette redoutable mise à l'épreuve
[Musique]
deux heures plus tard il a droit à une
séance de simulation vidéo tu es prêt
pour l'arrimage capteurs sur la tête
romain s'entraîne pour la première fois
à une manoeuvre qu'il devra maîtriser
quand il sera dans le module arrimer un
vaisseau spatial à une station orbitale
[Musique]
la vitesse est bonne
sur l'écran les deux croix doivent
coïncider parfaitement
dans l'espace c'est exactement le même
procédé
ici les commandes utilisés sont
identiques alors romain est sur un petit
nuage
c'est des vrais manettes qu'on peut voir
dans dans le vaisseau qu'utilisent les
cosmonautes actuellement donc je touche
les manettes que que les quelques
centaines de personnes qui sont allées
dans l'espace ont entre les mains ça
vous fait quoi
c'est sympa j'aime beaucoup tu dois te
souvenir tout seul de la bonne
trajectoire
l'exercice est délicat ben tout au long
de la mission
les capteurs mesurerons le degré de
vigilance de romain afin de vérifier une
donnée essentielle
après 520 jours de confinement
un pilote est il toujours capable de
ramener son vaisseau sur terre
[Musique]
mais la grande inconnue d'un voyage vers
mars
ce sera aussi les relations au sein même
de l'équipage et celui-ci est plutôt
hétéroclite
jeudi dernier c'était le jour j
mais si martiaux note pouce devant les
caméras du monde entier avant de
s'enfermer dans le module pour un an et
demi aux côtés de romain il ya diego
mais aussi un participant chinois et
trois russes un équipage international
comme sans doute celui de la future
vraie mission sur mars
mais comment faire cohabiter durant 520
jours des gens de cultures si
différentes
un mois avant le départ romain était
confronté à la question de manière très
concrète
content de vous voir
il est 4 heures de l'après midi
et pour fêter dignement l'anniversaire
de misha un coéquipier russe c'est votre
cas obligatoire en france et paraît que
c'est tous les jours que vous buvez du
nord a priori pas facile pour romain de
s'adapter aux traditions locales
seule solution faire bonne figure et
accepté le défi
le but c'est vraiment rester 520 jours
ensemble qu'il faut que qui est une
sorte de mayonnaise que la sauce prenne
et que et qu'on arrive à travailler
ensemble et à tenir ensemble surtout
donc voilà dommage que je ne comprenne
rien mais je suis sûr que tu as dit que
des trucs sympas un premier vers un 2e
romain semble prêt à tous les sacrifices
pour s'intégrer à l'équipe surtout qu
une fois enfermés ils ne pourront boire
qu'un seul verre d'alcool
ce sera du vin chaud lyophilisée pour
fêter noël
la tête dans les étoiles mais les pieds
bien sur terre